สวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊กสวัสดีค่ะครูบีสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนค่ะค่ะสวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคน
เช่นกันค่ะค่ะขอต้อนรับนักเรียนทุกคนนะคะ
เข้าสู่ห้องเรียน comprehensible  Thai
ค่ะห้องเรียนภาษาไทยแบบธรรมชาตินะคะใช่
ค่ะครูปุ๊กวันนี้เรามาเจอกันในวันอะไรคะ
วันนี้เนี่ยเป็นวันพุธค่ะนะวันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันนี้วันที่ 14 ค่ะนะเดือนอะไรคะ
กุมภาพันธ์ค่ะอ่าปีพ.ศล่ะคะ
2567 ค่ะปีค.ศล่ะคะ
2024 ค่ะวันนี้ก็แฮปปี้วาเลนไทน Day นะ
คะนะวันพุธที่ 14 กุมภาพันธ์ปีพุทธศักราช
2567 ปีคริสตศักราช 2020  14 ค่ะค่ะก็
แฮปปี้วันวาเลนไทนนะคะนักเรียนทุกคนขอให้
มีความสุขนะสุขสันวันวาเลนไทน์อื้อหือใช่
ค่ะขอให้เพราะฉะนั้นนะครูปุ๊กเราต้องไป
เที่ยวค่ะอือ้าไปเที่ยวดีค่ะครูบีครูบีจะ
ไปยังไงคะอ่าครูไปที่ไหนก่อนครู
บีต้องหาก่อนค่ะโอโหหาผู้ชายพาไปเที่ยว
อันนี้ยากเลย
นะเอ้าไปเที่ยวเนี่ยมันต้องมีคนเปยคน
สปอนเซอร์นะครู
ปุ๊กเดินทางอืโอ้โหแต่ถ้าเรารีบอ่ะเราหา
ผู้ชายไม่ทันค่ะอืงั้นครูปุ๊กไปกับครูบี
มั้ยเดี๋ยววันนี้พาไปเที่ยวอ่าได้ค่ะครู
ปุ๊กอยากไปที่ที่แบบแบบไม่ใช่คนเยอะๆอ่ะ
เพราะวันนี้วาเลนไทน์เนี่ยทุกที่คนจะเยอะ
ๆใช่มั้ยมีคนเยอะมีที่ไหนที่แบบคนไม่ต้อง
เยอะมากค่ะครูบีมีค่ะครูปุ๊กงั้นครูปุ๊ก
กับครูบีเเนี่ยจะไปเอ่อโรแมนติกใช่มั้ยคะ
คนไปดูคนอื่น
โรแมนติกไปที่เงียบๆมีคนนิดหน่อยเนี่ยปู
ปุ๊กคิดถึงเลยค่ะต้องไปจังหวัดที่มีเกาะ
ค่ะ
ออโอ้โหจังหวัดที่มีเกาะมีเยอะค่ะใน
ประเทศไทยเบีโอ้โหถ้าไปภูเก็ตภูเก็ตเนี่
ก็เป็นเกาะใช่มยแพงค่ะไม่ไปเอแล้วก็มีคน
เยอะอ่าถ้าไปเอ่อเกาะพงันก็มีคนเยอะแล้ว
ก็แพงมีทั้งนักท่องเที่ยวเยอะใช่มั้ย
เดี๋ยววันนี้จะใช่เกาะที่มีนักท่องเที่ยว
นิดหน่อยอืมสมีนิดหน่อยมีคนไทยนิดหน่อยมี
ฝรั่งนิดหน่อยทุกอย่างนิด
หน่อยแต่ว่าครูบีคะมันไม่ได้อยู่แบบแบบไป
แบบ
อื้อหือเค้าเรียกถิ่นทุรกันดารหมายถึงว่า
ไม่มีทางถนนนะอาจจะมีต้นไม้ต้นไม้เยอะๆ
ค่ะเป็นป่าหรือเปล่าปูปุ๊กสบายใจได้ค่ะ
เดินทางไปไม่ยากเลยค่ะครูปุ๊กเพราะว่า
สามารถเดินทางได้แบบหลายๆแบบเลยนะคะ
เดี๋ยวจะพาครูปุ๊กไปจังหวัดนี้เลยค่ะ
จังหวัดระนองครูปุ๊กเคยไปมั้ยโอไม่เคยค่ะ
ได้ยินชื่อเสียงเหมือนกันเนาะแต่ว่าถ้า
เป็นแหล่งท่องเที่ยวเนี่ยนักเรียนอาจจะ
ไม่ไม่ค่อยรู้จักหรอกจังหวัดระนองเพราะ
ว่าเรามีทั้งหมดเนี่ย 77 จังหวัดเนาะก็จะ
มีจังหวัดที่นักเรียนเนี่ยมาทีนึงก็จะไป
อาจจะไปรู้จักแต่เชียงใหม่นะภูเก็ตนะ
กรุงเทพฯแล้วก็อาจจะไป
พัทยานะอย่างอื่นอาจจะไม่รู้จักแล้วค่ะ
ชลบุรีไปสุรินทร์ก็ได้นะบ้านครูบีนะคะภาค
อีสานนะคะผู้หญิงสวยที่สุดนะจังหวัดสุอ่า
ในประเทศไทยมั้ยอ่าสวยที่สุดในประเทศไทย
นะอยู่ที่จังหวัดสุรินทร์นะคะอ่าเพราะว่า
ครูบีเป็นเป็นคนบอกเองใช่นะคะแต่ถ้าตอน
นี้เราอยู่กรุงเทพฯเนาะหมายเลข 1 นะคะใช่
ค่ะอ่าเราต้องลงมาทางนี้ค่ะครูปุ๊กจะพาไป
ภาคใต้นะแต่ไม่ไม่ได้แบบไปถึงภูเก็ตนะอ
อาฮะจังหวัดระนองเนี่ยอยู่ตรงนี้ค่ะเห็น
มั้ยคะอือ่าเห็นแล้วค่ะนะเพราะว่าจังหวัด
ระนองเนี่ยจะไม่ใช่ระยองนะคะนักเรียนต้อง
ฟังดีๆนะระองอืมเดี๋ยวซูมซูมเข้าไปอีก
อ่าเนี่ยค่ะหมายเลข 1 นี่คือกรุงเทพฯนะคะ
แล้วก็ลงมาหมายเลข 6 หมายเลข 7 เข้ามา
จังหวัดเพชรบุรีนะจังหวัดประจวบเห็นมั้ย
คะพอสีฟ้าเนี่ยเริ่มเป็นภาคใต้แล้วนะคะ
ครูปุ๊กใช่ค่ะจังหวัดชุมพรนะแล้วก็
จังหวัดระนองเนี่ยจะอยู่ติดทางฝั่งประเทศ
เมียนมาร์นะหรือว่าประเทศพม่านะคะตรงนี้
ใช่ค่ะก็คือเป็นทะเลอันดามัน
นะแล้วก็จังหวัดระนองเนี่ยมีชื่อเสียง
เกี่ยวกับน้ำน้ำแร่ค่ะเหมือนฝรั่งเศสมี
เอเวียงอือหือเอเวียงออกเสียงถูกมั้ย
เนี่ยเป็นน้ำแร่น้ำที่จากดินใช่มั้ยแล้ว
ก็พุ่งขึ้นมาแล้วก็ร้อนมากๆเนี่ยอแล้วก็
นะนั่นแหละที่จังหวัดระนองเนี่ยเา้าบอก
ว่ามีน้ำแรกที่ดีที่สุดในประเทศไทยด้วย
อืมแล้วเป็นจังหวัดที่ไม่ใหญ่นะครูปุ๊ก
เนี่ยใช่นี่จะเป็นแผนที่จังหวัดระนองนะคะ
อืออ่ามีแค่ 5 อำเภอเองค่ะครูปุ๊กเล็กๆ
เนาะเพราะว่าตรงช่วงเนี้ยมันเป็นช่วงแคบๆ
ของประเทศไทยเนาะ
นะช่วงภาคใต้เนี่ยครูปุ๊กอยากไปที่เงียบๆ
คนนิดหน่อยใช่มั้ยคะอ่าใช่ค่ะใชิไปพัก
ผ่อนไปนอนดูธรรมชาติอ่าใช่ปต้องไปพักผ่อน
ไปพักผ่อนเราอยากไปที่เงียบๆเนาะไปพัก
ผ่อนจริงๆไม่ใช่แบบไปแล้วคนเยอะแยะโอ้โห
มีแต่เสียงดังๆก็ไม่โอเคนะูนี่ปุ๊กเห็นมย
คะเนี่ยครูปุ๊กเนี่ยก็จะเห็นว่าจังหวัด
ระนองเนี่ยก็จะมีเกาะเห็นมั้ยคะนี่มีเกาะ
ช้างด้วยนะมีเกาะที่ชื่อว่าเกาะช้างด้วย
แต่ครูบดีอยากพาครูปุ๊กไปเนี่ยเกาะพยาม
ค่ะอ๋อเพราะว่าเกาะช้างเนี่ยมีทั้งฝั่ง
อ่าวไทยแล้วก็มีทั้งฝั่งอันดามันเนาะนะ
ชื่อเกาะช้างเหมือนกันแต่คนละคนละทิศนะฮะ
คนละทะเลค่ะอืคือจังหวัดระนองเนี่ยก็จะมี
เกาะเกาะเกาหมู่เกาะตรงบริเวณทะเล
อันดามันเนี่ยสวยนะคะครูปุ๊กแล้วก็ก็เกาะ
พยายามเนี่ยน่าสนใจมากนะคะ
อ่าไปค่ะไปค่ะเพราะว่าูปุ๊กก็เคยได้ยิน
ว่าเกาะพยามเนี่ยนะมีคนไปถ่ายรูปมาโอ้โห
สวยมากกูบีไปเคยได้ยินใช่มั้ยใช่เอาๆเอา
เสื้อผ้าเลยมั้ยคะเก็บเสื้อ
ผ้านะเราไปสัก 2 วัน 3 วันก็ได้นะครูปุ๊ก
แต่ว่าก่อนที่เราจะไปเนี่ยเราต้องรู้ก่อน
ว่าเราจะเดินทางไปยังไงค่ะ
อืมันมีไปได้กี่วิธีคะรูบีอ่าไปได้เนี่ย
อันดับแรกเลยนะคะมีหลายวิธีนะครูปุ๊กถ้า
ครูปุ๊กอยู่กรุงเทพฯใช่่มั้ยคะครูปุ๊ก
เนี่ยอยากจะไปรถยนต์ส่วนตัวหรือเปล่าคะรถ
ยนต์ส่วนตัวได้ค่ะเพราะว่าครูบีมีรถค่ะ
อ่าแต่ว่าเอ่อครูบีมีรถยนต์ส่วนตัวค่ะแต่
ว่าไม่มีเงินเติมน้ำมันเบนซินดีเซลค่ะอ๋อ
ไม่เป็นไรค่ะครูบีขับแล้วก็ครูกุ๊กเนี่ย
เติมเบนซินให้โอ้จริงหรอคะจริงสิคะก็นะรถ
ครูบีแต่ครูปุ๊กเนี่ยเติมน้ำมันครูบีขับ
ครูปุ๊กนอนสบายค่ะเห็นมมีรถยนต์ส่วนตัวนะ
คะเอออืแต่ข้างหลังนัเป็นแท็กซี่ไม่ใช่
ส่วนตัวใช่มยใช่อันนี้เป็นรถแท็กซี่นะคะ
แต่ครูบีเเนี่ยมีรถยนต์ส่วนตัวนะคะก็เรา
จะไปกัน 2 คนนะขับรถยนต์ไป
อ้าถ้าเดินทางนอะไรนะคะรู้มั้ยว่าใช้เวลา
กี่ชั่วโมง
โอ้โหกรุงเทพฯไปจังหวัดระนองเนี่ยครูปุ๊ก
ต้องบอกก่อนว่ากี่กิโลเมตเอ้ออ่าได้ๆๆๆ
เพราะว่าบางบางคนอาจจะขับรถเร็วก็อาจจะ
ใช้เวลาน้อยบางคนเนี่ยขับรถช้าๆอืก็อาจจะ
ใช้เวลานานอ่าคิดว่าครูบีน่าจะขับช้านะ
เพราะว่าครูปุ๊กก็อาจจะครูบีจอดหิวอ่ากิน
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวใช่มยกินส้มตำโอ้โหอ่าพอขับไป
อีกก็ครูบีเข้าห้องน้ำ
อครูบีของกินอีกแล้วเพราะครูบีกับครูปุ๊ก
ชอบกินนะคะก็ระยะทางกรุงเทพฯไปจังหวัด
ระนองนี่นะครูปุ๊กประมาณ
568 กมนะคะอื 500 กว่ากิโมเนี่ยคิดว่าก็
ขับรถนานเหมือนกันนะนานค่ะถ้าขับช้าก็ 7-8
ชมเนาะถ้าขับเร็วก็ 5 ชมได้นะคะเาแต่แตู่
ปุ๊กอย่าลืมว่าขับลงไปทางภาคใต้เนี่ยถนน
เนี่ยโอหถ้าเราขับรถไม่เก่งเนี่ยก็ก็ต้อง
ระวังต้องขับช้าๆเนาะอ่าใช่ค่ะเพราะว่า
เค้าบอกว่าเส้นทางที่ไปผ่านระนองเนี่ยมัน
จะมีภูเขาภูเขาเยอะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยทาง
มันก็อาจจะคดเคี้ยวนะอืแล้วเบอกว่าบริเวณ
ที่จะไปถึงอ่าจังหวัดระนองเนี่ยนะคะจาก
ชุมพรใช่มั้ยจังหวัดชุมพรไประนองเนี่ย
ประมาณ 12 กมที่จะถึงจังหวัดระนองเนี่ย
ตรงเนี้ยเบอกว่าโอ้โหถนนเนี่ยอันตรายนะคะ
ต้องช้าๆค่ะ
อือย่าขับเร็วนะคะอ่าอืมเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ย
ก็ต้องใช้เวลานานขึ้นอีกอาจจะ 10 ชมง
เพราะว่าครูบีขับใช่นะครูบีก็จะขับ 40 กม
ต่อชั่วมง
ได้ค่ะไม่เป็นไรค่ะเพราะว่าครูปุ๊งเนี่ย
ขับรถไม่ได้ครูปุ๊งยอมอืมนะอันนี้คือการ
เดินทางวิธีที่ 1 เนาะก็คือมีรถยนต์ส่วน
ตัวนะคะวิธีที่ 2 ค่ะครูปุ๊กเราก็เดินทาง
โดยรถประจำทางอืนะรถประจำทางก็จะมีรถบัส
รถเมอืใช่มรถประจำทางก็คือวิ่งตั้งอาจจะ
กรุงเทพฯไประนองหรือกรุงเทพฯไปภูเก็ตแต่
แวะนะชุมพรแวะละนองมองแวะนะแวะไปเรื่อยๆเ
กรุงเทพพัทยาค่ะไม่ใช่แต่รถจะเหมือนกัน
ใช่มั้ยเป็นรถบัสรถทัวร์นะคนไทยก็เรียก
ว่ารถทัวร์นะคะก็จะมี
กรุงเทพธานีเก็ตนะมีกรุงเทพเชียงใหม่อัน
นี้จะเป็นรถประจำทางเพราะว่าวิ่งประจำทาง
นะจากกรุงเทพฯไปจังหวัดระนองจากกรุงเทพฯ
ไปจังหวัดเชียงใหม่อย่างเงี้ยค่ะนะก็จะ
เป็นรถทัวร์แบบนี้เนาะค่ะแล้วก็มีแอร์ค่ะ
อันนี้มีแอร์ค่ะรูบีใช่นะเป็นเป็นรถมี
แอร์นะคะใช่แร์คนิเนแต่ว่าเเราเรียกว่า
เครื่องปรับอากาศรถปรับอากาศค่ะบางที
เนี่ยนักเรียนจะเห็นเค้าเขียนว่าเ
ปอแล้วก็อาจจะมีตัวเลขเนปอ 1 ปอ 2 อย่าง
เงี้ยก็คือเป็นรถปรับอากาศอืมีแอร์ 2 ใช่
แล้วก็มีรถแบบไม่มีแอร์แต่ราคาเนี่ยไม่
แพงสำหรับคนที่มีเงินนิดหน่อยแล้วอยากจะ
ไปเที่ยวแบบนะไกลๆได้ก็อาจจะแบบเก็บเงิน
ไว้เดินทางเนี่ยก็อาจจะนั่งรถที่ไม่มี
แอร์ไปก็ได้อือราคาก็จะถูอันนี้เราเนี่ย
จะไปจังหวัดระนองจังหวัดระนองอยู่ทางภาค
ใต้ใช่มั้ยครูปุ๊กก็รถทัวร์เนี่ยจะไม่ไป
ขึ้นที่หมหมอชิดนะคะเราจะเดินทางไปที่าย
ใต้ใช่นะครูปุ๊ใอยู่แถวไหนน่าจะใกล้ๆ
BTS  BTS มีมั้ยเดินทางทาง BTS อืมไม่
แน่ใจนะคิดว่าอาจจะยังไม่มีนะเพราะว่าสาย
ใต้อ่ะมันจะมีสายใต้ใหม่สายใต้เก่านะก็
ไม่เป็นไรครูปุ๊กก็นั่งแท็กซี่ไปขนส่งสาย
ใต้นะใช่อ่าก็คือคือมันจะมีรถทัวร์เนาะ
ที่เดินทางไปทางภาคใต้นะก็จะเป็นอ่าสถานี
มีรถทัวร์เยอะเลยนะสถานีขนส่งอันนี้ก็บอก
แท็กซี่แล้วเราก็ไปนั่งรถทัวร์ที่สายใต้
ได้นะคะอันนี้ก็คือจะเป็นการเดินทางโดย
อ่ารถทัวร์เนาะรถประจำทางอ่ะวิธีที่ 3
ค่ะครูปุ๊กใครชอบแบบโรแมนติกแบบโอ้โห
วาเลนไทนใช่มั้ยที่แบบอยากนั่งแบบนานๆ
นั่งรถนานๆค่ะ
อืนั่งรถนานๆนั่งรถอะไรคะอันนี้จะ
โรแมนติกมากนะครูปุ๊กรถไฟค่ะอ๋อเพราะว่า
รถไฟประเทศไทยเนี่ยไม่ได้เร็วเหมือนชิง
กันเซ็นใช่มั้ย
คะเออเราอาจจะ 40 กมต่อช่มค่ะนะคนไม่มี
แฟนไปก็อาจจะเป็นแฟนกันนะอืนะคนที่มีเป็น
แฟนกันไปก็อาจจะแต่งงานในรถเลยขอแต่งงาน
รถไฟเนี่ยจะวิ่งช้าเนาะ
40 ต่อชั่วโมงนะฉึกฉักฉึกฉักไม่เป็นไร
ค่ะไปกับผู้ชายหล่อผู้หญิงสวยเนี่ยโอเคนะ
คะแต่ไปกับครูปุ๊กเนี่ยครูบีไม่ไปรถไฟนะ
คะกลัวเห็นครูปุ๊กนานๆเหรอคะใช่ค่ะก็จะ
เบื่อหน้าครูปุ๊กนะคะไปรถยนต์ส่วนตัวก
โอเคนะคะูปุ๊ก็ไม่อยากไปรถไฟค่ะทำไมอ่ะคะ
ของกินน้อยค่ะอืใช่มั้ยไปรถยนต์ส่วนตัว
เนี่ยหิวก็จอดอ่าซื้ออาหารใช่มยอยากดื่ม
กาแฟก็จอดซื้อกาแฟเอ้ออ่าคือรถไฟเนี่ยมัน
ก็มีตู้เา้าเรียกว่าตู้เสบียงตู้เสบียง
หมายถึงตู้ที่เป็นเกี่ยวกับอาหารเนาะค่ะ
ถ้าเราหิวเราก็สามารถที่จะไปนั่งที่ตู้
เสบียงก็ได้นะแล้วก็สั่งนะเขาคก็จะมีเมนู
ให้เราเลือกว่าเราจะกินอะไรนะหรือว่าบาง
ทีเนี่ยมีพนักงานรถไฟเนี่ยเดินมาแล้วคุณ
ก็เรียกได้แล้วก็สั่งกินที่ที่นั่งตัวเอง
ได้เหมือนกันใช่นะอันนี้ก็ถ้าคนที่ชอบอาจ
จะเบื่อนั่งรถทัวร์ใช่มั้ยคะอ่าก็อยากจะ
นั่งรถไฟบ้างนะเปลี่ยนวิธีการเดินทางนะก็
นั่งรถไฟได้แต่อาจจะใช้เวลานานหน่อยนะคะ
อุ้ยถ้าเกิดว่าอย่างเงี้ยเราก็วางแผนสิคะ
ครูบีมากๆเก็จะเดินทางตอนเย็นค่ะอแล้วก็
ไปเช้าที่นู่นอือ่าไปจังหวัดระนองเนี่ย
อ่าสถานีรถไฟที่ระนองก็เช้าพอดีใช่มั้ย
แล้วนั่งรถไฟคือราคาไม่แพงไงครูปุ๊กใช่รถ
ไฟก็มีหลายๆราคาด้วยนะแล้วก็มีแบบรถรถไฟ
ธรรมดานั่งไปเนี่ยแต่เก้าอี้แข็งเนาะมัน
ก็จะแบบไม่แพงจริงแต่ว่าเมื่อยค่ะอือืนะ
เมื่อยแต่ถ้าเราเนี่ยเอ่อเพิ่มเงินอีกนิด
นึงเขาก็จะมีแบบตู้นอนค่ะเราสามารถนอนบน
รถไฟได้เขาก็จะมาปรับเก้าอี้ให้เป็นเตียง
นอนนะเคก็จะมีเตียงนอนเนี่ย 2 ชั้นนะเรา
จะนอนชั้นล่างหรือชั้นบนถ้านอนชั้นล่าง
เนี่ยแพงมากกว่านอนชั้นบนอืนะอย่างครูบี
ตัวเล็กๆอ่ะนอนข้างบนก็โอเคค่ะไม่ต้อง
กลัวตกลง
มาไม่ต้องกลัวตกน้ำหนักไงถ้ากูกครูปุ๊ก
นอนข้างบนครูบีนอนข้างล่างเนี่ยครูปุ๊ก
หนักใช่มั้ยรถอาจจะวิ่งจึกๆึๆๆๆึลงมาทำ
ยังไงอแต่ยังไม่เคยมีนะคะที่รถไฟเยังไม่
เคยมียังไม่เคยมีชั้ส่องลงมาอ๋อคือรถไฟ
เนี่ยก็มีรถไฟธรรมดาแล้วก็รถไฟที่แบบอ่า
สามารถนอนได้ใช่มั้ยคะเป็นรถไฟขบวนพิเศษ
นะคะอ่ะวิธีต่อไปค่ะก็คือถ้าไม่ชอบนั่งรถ
นานๆชอบแบบเร็วๆเร็วๆค่ะอือฮึทำยังไงคะ
นั่งเครื่องบินค่ะ
อ๋อมีเหรอคะครูบีมีเครื่องบินไปลงที่
จังหวัดระนองมั้ยมีค่ะค่ะแต่ไม่ใช่สายการ
บินนี้นะคะอืเอาเครื่องบินมาให้ดูอ่าอัน
นี้เป็นเครื่องบินเนาะแต่ว่าจะเป็น
เครื่องบินเ่อของประเทศไทยนะวิ่งอ่าบินใน
ประเทศไทยก็คือสายการบินนกแอร์อืมนะเป็น
สายการบินนกแอร์นะคะนะแล้วก็อ่อสามารถบิน
จากสนามบินดอนเมืองเนาะแล้วก็ไปลงที่สนาม
บินจังหวัดระนองนะคะแล้วเค้ามีบริการด้วย
นะคะอ่าเราสามารถเช็คในเว็บไซต์
อินเทอร์เน็ตได้หมดพอครูปุ๊กนั่งเครื่อง
บินไปลงที่เมืองระนองใช่มั้ยถ้าครูปุ๊ก
เนี่ยต้องการแบบสะดวกสบายอยากไปเที่ยว
เกาะอ่าอยากไปเที่ยวเกาะพยามอย่างเงี้ย
ครูปุ๊กก็เค้ามีบริการเอ่อมีรถรับส่งนะ
จากสนามบินเนี่ยไปถึงท่าเรือที่เราจะไป
เที่ยวเกาะพยามได้นะรักราคาก็ประมาณ
200-250 บาทนะคะต่อเที่ยวนะคะก็ถือว่า
สะดวกนะแล้วก็ประหยัดเวลาด้วยนะคะใช่ก็ดี
นะครูบีค่ะอืเพราะว่าจากจากสนามบินระนอง
เนี่ยไปถึงอ่าบริเวณท่าเรือนะตรงปากน้ำ
ที่เราจะนั่งเรือไปเกาะพยายามเนี่ยก็ใช้
เวลาแค่ 30 นาทีนะคะค่ะหรือว่าอันนี้ก็
คือที่ที่ที่เรารู้ใช่มว่าเคจะเดินทางได้
แบบไหนบ้างใช่มย
นะแล้ว
ถ้านักเรียนเนี่ยไม่รู้ว่าไปเที่ยวยังไง
ไปยังไงคิดว่าไปกับทัวร์ก็ได้นะิอใช่นะ
เพราะว่าอย่างเช่นถนนข้าวสารเนี่ยเขาก็จะ
มีบริษัททัว์เยอะใช่มยนะเราก็อาจจะแบบไป
ติดต่อกับบบสัตทัวร์แล้วก็เค้าก็จะมีรถมา
รับนะส่วนมากก็จะเป็นรถตู้นะแต่โอ้โหบุ๊ก
เนี่ยเอามาเล็กมากเดี๋ยวขยายให้ค่ะอืรถ
ตู้แบบนี้ค่ะนะแล้วก็นั่งนั่งมาเขาก็จะ
แบบเหมือนพาไปถึงโรงแรมที่พักอะไรอย่าง
เงี้ยนะออก็จะเป็นรถตู้แบบ vip เนาะอ่า
อันนี้คือตอนนี้มันสะดวกสบายเพราะว่าว่า
เรามีอินเทอร์เน็ตนะเราสามารถจอง Booking
ในเว็บไซต์ในบริษัททัวร์ได้สบายเลยนะแต่
ถ้าเราอ่าอยากไปด้วยตัวเองแล้วก็ไปรถยนต์
ส่วนตัวเนาะหรือว่านักเรียนอยากจะไปแบบ
นั่งรถทัวร์ใช่มยอ่าก็ลองลองดูนะคะก็จะมี
เว็บไซต์เยอะแยะนะอ่าเสิร์ชข้อมูลหาได้
แบบตามเว็บไซต์เลยว่าจะเดินทางยังไงนะคะ
ทีเนี้ยเดี๋ยวจะพาไปชมค่ะครูปุ๊กเรามี
เวลานิดหน่อยไงให้นักเรียนเห็นว่าเกาะ
พยายามที่ครูบีอยากพานักเรียนไปเที่ยว
เนี่ยสวยม
เออนะต้องสวยแน่นอนค่ะบุ๊กการันตี
ค่ะถึงไม่เคยไปแต่ว่าครูุก็เคยเห็นนะรูป
หรือว่าที่ทีวีใช่่มไปถ่ายที่เกาะนี้เยอะ
นะคะแล้วก็อาจจะมี
เอ่อหนังนะหนังไทยหรือหรือว่าเป็นซีรีส์
ไทยเนี่ยไปถ่ายที่เกาะนี้ด้วยอืมนะเพราะ
ว่าถ้าคุณไปถึงเกาะพยามใช่มั้ยไปถึงท่า
เรือเนี่ยคุณก็สามารถแบบนั่งค่ะนั่งเรือ
สปีดโบทอะไรก็ได้เนาะจะมีเรือเนี่ยก็
เกือบเกือบ 1
ชมงไปเกาะพยายามนะคะถ้าถ้าเป็นแบบเรือ
เร็วใช่มยก็ก็ใช้เวลานิดหน่อยนะคะแต่ถ้า
เป็นที่นั่งหลายๆคนเนาะเรือใหญ่เนี่ยก็ 1
ช่วโมงครึ่งนะคะเกือบ 2 ชั่วโมงอย่าง
เงี้ยค่ะอคือข้อดีของสปีดโบก็คือว่าเรา
เนี่ยเช่านะจ่ายเงินเหมารำใช่มยก็กรุ๊บ
เรากรุ๊บเดียวแล้วก็ไปไปตอนกี่โมงมันก็
โอเคไงแต่ถ้าเรารอเรือใหญ่อ่ะเรือแบบเรือ
ที่เา้าเป็นเรือโดยสารเนาะนะเราก็อาจจะ
ต้องใช้เวลารอตามรอบของเขาอาจจะ 1 ช่มออก
1  1 ลำใช่ม 1 ช่ม 1 ลำอะไรแบบนี้นะเรา
ก็ต้องรอรอเ้าค่ะอืก็ต้องนั่งเรือไปนะคะ
อ่ะเดี๋ยวมีบรรยากาศเป็นวดีโอเนาะใน
YouTube ให้ดูนิดหน่อยนะคะให้ดูนิดหน่อย
ค่ะนะนักเรียนบอกโอ้โหพอเห็นแล้วเนี่ยรู้
สึกแบบ๊อยากมาอยากมาเที่ยว
น่าไม่ใช่แต่ภูเก็ตนะที่นักเรียนรู้จัก
แล้วจะคิดว่ามันสวยที่เดียวนะคะโเห็นมั้ย
คะภาพอืตัวอย่างนะคะอ่าอันนี้พอมาถึงท่า
เรือเห็นมั้ยคะก็ 11:30 นนะตรงเก็จะเรือ
เนี่ยจะออกไปที่เกาะพยามนะคะ
อ่าเห็นมั้ยเร็วมั้ยคะถึงแล้วนะ
คะประมาณ 45 นาทีนะคะอ่านี่นะก็จะมีเกาะ
พยามนะคะส่วนเรามาพอเรามาถึงเกาะเนี่ยก็
คือครูปุ๊กจองโรงแรมจองรีสอร์ทที่ไหนก็
สะดวกสบายเลยค่ะนี่จะรถใช่มั้ยนั่งต่อไป
ค่ะนะคือจ่ายเงินค่ารถโดยสารอืมนะอันนี้
ก็จะไปรีสอร์ทนะคะอ่าเนี่ยค่ะจริงๆไม่
ต้องนั่งรถก็ได้นะครูปุ๊กเพราะว่าเดิน
เนี่ย 10 นาทีค่ะอันนี้เป็นเอ่อเ่อที่มี
ชื่อเสียงมากในเกาะพยามก็คือ Blue  Sky
รีสอร์นะคะเขาบอกว่าเป็นดฟ Thailand อือื
นั่นแหละค่ะแต่มีรถบริการฟรีนะคะเมื่อกี้
อ่าของรีสอร์ทใช่มั้ยใช่ก็มารับนักท่อง
เที่ยวเนโอ๊ยมีเรือแคนนูด้วยค่ะใช่นะก็จะ
มีช่วงเวลาที่อ่าน้ำทะเลขึ้นแล้วก็น้ำ
ทะเลเนี่ยลดลงนะคะอ่าอันนี้ก็จะเป็นอ่า
บริเวณรีสอร์ทนี่คือติดทะเลเลยนะคะอ๋อมี
เปด้วยูบีน่านอนนะใช่มีเปยให้นอนนะคะมีตะ
ว่ายน้ำอื
โอ้เปิดเข้าไปค่ะห้องนอนมีเตียงนอนนะแล้ว
ก็มีที่นั่งนะออกไปที่ระเบียงดูโอ้อันนี้
ห้องน้ำห้องน้ำเดี๋ยวๆไอ้ไม้พระไนี่เอามา
พายพายเรือเหรอคะพายเรือในห้องน้ำอ่างอาบ
น้ำนะเป็นเรืออืมอันนี้ก็อาจจะเป็นห้อง
ที่ราคาเนี่ยเริ่มต้นนะคะเพราะว่าจะมี
หลายราคามากนะคะบู Sky รีสอร์ทนะ
อือันนี้คือติดทะเลเลยนะครูปุ๊กค่ะแล้วก็
มีสระว่ายน้ำเล็กๆเนาะให้สำหรับแบบเอ่อ
ถ้าเราแบบเล่นน้ำทะเลบ้างแล้วก็มาเล่นน้ำ
สระบ้าง
ออนะอ่ะอันนี้คือเป็นคลิปที่แบบเมารีวิว
นะก็เช่าห้องที่มันเป็นราคาเนี่ยไม่ไม่
ได้แพงมากนะเริ่มต้นที่ 1 คืน 3,000 บาท
อย่างเงี้ยค่ะแต่ถ้าเป็นแบบเอ่อราคาแพงนะ
คะก็จะต้องเป็นอันนี้เลย
เนาะอันนี้ค่ะที่เราบอกว่ามีเรือธนูเหรอ
ครูปุ๊กเเรียกเรือเรือเรียกอะไรเรือแคนนู
แคนนูใช่มั้ยใช่นะเป็นเรือพายให้เราเนี่ย
นะไปทำแบบเหมือนกิจกรรมไงไม่รู้ทำอะไร
อยู่หลายวันก็เราก็พายเรือเล่นออกกำลัง
กายแล้วก็นะถ่าย
รูปอ่ะอันนี้มุมสูงนะอันนี้คือ Blue  Sky
รีสอร์ทเห็นมั้ยคะอก็ถ้ามีน้ำทะเลขึ้นสูง
นะคุณก็พาย
เรือสนุกได้เลยนะคะแล้วก็ถ้าเป็นรีสอร์ท
อันนี้นะคะค่อนข้างราคาแพงหน่อยนะคะอ่าก็
แล้วแต่ว่าคุณไปช่วงไหนถ้า High ซีซั่นก็
แพงนะราคาอยู่ที่ 1 คืนประมาณ 6,000 ถึง
10,000 บาท 20,000 บาทนะคะอืนะเค้าก็น่า
จะมีอาหารให้เนาะอาหารเช้ามีค่ะมีอาหาร
เช้าอันนี้บรรยากาศตอนเย็นก็ไปเที่ยวชาย
หาดจะมีทรายสีดำด้วยนะคะอออันนี้ก็จะเป็น
เอ่อเคเรียกว่าเขาทะลุเขาทะลุค่ะอันนี้นก
เงือกค่ะหรือนกกระหังภาคใต้เจะเรียกนก
กระหังนะคือนกเงือกนกเงือกเนี่ยเขาจะอยู่
ที่ป่าที่มันสมบูรณ์ก็คือมีต้นไม้เยอะมี
อาหารอุดมสมบูรณ์มีอาหารมากๆค่ะเถึงจะ
อยู่นะเค้าก็จะนั่งเรือไปเที่ยวนะคะอ่ะ
เดี๋ยวให้ดูอีกที่นึงที่น่าสนใจก็คือเขา
บอกว่าเป็นรีสอร์ทแบบ
บ้านบ้านที่แบบอยู่ในป่าค่ะครูปุ๊ก
โอ้โหจะไปเป็น
ทาซาทาซานเหรอคะใช่ภาษาไทยเนี่ยทาซานอื
แต่ถ้าบอกนักเรียนนักเรียนไม่รู้จักค่ะ
อ๋อนักเรียนไม่รู้จักทาซานนะคะถ้าถ้าภาษา
ไทยแบบเราเนี่ยเขาก็จะงงๆนะทาซานคืออะไร
อืมนะเห็นเห็นมมีสำหรับไปดำน้ำดูปะการัง
นะคะนี่ค่ะสวยมีาปลาการ์ตูนด้วยอ่ะเา้า
เรียกว่าบ้านในหมงอ้านะจะอยู่ในป่านะครู
ปุ๊กเออบรรยากาศก็ดีนะแล้วก็มีโอโหมีน้ำ
น้ำตกน้ำไฟนะสวยมั้ยครูปุ๊กครูปุ๊กชอบบ
ใช่มสวยชอบชอบๆอแบบนี้ชอบเลยค่ะครูบีไป
อันนี้ก็ได้ค่ะนี่นะก็ไปเที่ยวน้ำตกนะคะ
อืนะไปเล่นน้ำค่ะครูปุ๊กไปว่ายน้ำออดีค่ะ
สวยด้วยนะถ้าอย่างงั้นเนี่ยถ้าไปแบบนี้
เนี่ยควนถ้าน้ำตกเหรอภาคใต้เค้าก็ฝนตก
หลังจากเราตกเนานะเคมีนี่ไปกินอาหารใต้
ค่ะอเต้มยำกุ้งอื้อหือมีอะไรเนี่ยขนมพก
เอ่อห่อหมกมีเอลวิส
ด้วย
อโอ๊ยน่ากินมากค่ะนี่อันนี้จะเป็นภูเขา
หญ้านะคะอ่าก็เป็นทุ่งใหญ่ๆเลยนะไปถ่าย
รูปได้นะอ๋อไปเล่นสไลเดอร์ได้มยคะไปเล่น
กีตาร์ค่ะเห็นมั้ยผู้ชายมีแฟน 2 คนนะคะ
เนี่ยแฟนคนที่ 1 คนที่ 2 โรแมนติก 3
คนโอ้โหดีมากอือันนี้ก็เป็นน้ำตกหงาวนะคะ
อ่าจริงๆมีสถานที่ท่องเที่ยวเยอะโอ้
เดี๋ยวครูบีลืมแนะนำนะก็จะมีบ่อน้ำพุร้อน
ด้วยนะครูปุ๊กอ่าแน่นอนค่ะที่จังหวัดนี้
มาต้องไปเล่นน้ำพุร้อนเนี่ยละค่ะน้ำที่
ขึ้นมาจากดินค่ะร้อนด้วยนักเรียนนะเลยน้ำ
พุร้อนจังหวัดระนองเรียดูไอน้ำร้อนขึ้นมา
เพราะฉะนั้นเ่ะลงไปแช่เลยไม่ได้นะคะนะ
เพราะมันจะรอร้อนมากต้มสุกเลยนะอืมนะถ้า
แบบนี้อาจจะโอเคนะเพราะว่าเขาจะมาพักน้ำ
ให้มันเย็นใช่นะเห็นมั้ยวิวสวยธรรมชาติ
สวยเสวยมากดีๆๆครูบีชอบที่นี่ค่ะอืคนนิด
หน่อยเห็นมั้ยคะอือฮะมองไปเห็นประเทศ
เมียนมาร์อย่างเงี้ยค่ะอือันนี้แค่ตัว
อย่างค่ะครูปุ๊กจริงๆอสกายรีสอร์ทเนี่ก็
เราไม่ได้ค่าคอมมิชชั่นนะคะสวยจะเห็นเค้า
สวยใช่มยใเห็นสวยนะคะก็ต้องไปเที่ยวเอง
บ้านในงบ้านในหหงก็ดีนะูุกชอบแบบนี้นะ
เหมือนปลานะแล้วเราสามารถเช่ามอเตอร์ไซค์
แล้วก็ขี่มอเตอร์ไซค์เทียบรอบอ่าเที่ยว
รอบเกาะนะคะ 200 บาทนะเราเช่ามอเตอร์ไซค์
ได้แล้วก็ไปดูชายหาดสวยๆนะคปุ๊กค่ะเพราะ
ฉะนั้นเนี่ยวันเนี้ยเรามาบอกนักเรียนชวน
นักเรียนไปนะลองไปดูนักเรียนเผื่อนัก
เรียนไม่รู้จักไงคะจังหวัดพนะไปเที่ยวเลย
ค่ะเกาะพยามนะคะค่ะวันนี้ก็หมดเวลาแล้ว
เนาะก็จะให้นักเรียนเนี่ยไปเที่ยวกับเรา
ทีหลังแล้วกันวันนี้ก็ขอบคุณครูบีค่ะแล้ว
ก็ขอบคุณนักเรียนด้วยค่ะสวัสดีค่ะค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะ